[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of beginner breakdown as always
my name is Alex and I'm super excited to
be back here with you it's been a the US
championships and everything else going
on on our stream but I'm excited to be
returning here for you and tonight I've
got a fun one this is something that
I'll be seeing on beginners uh
instruction for but this tactic this
idea is really relevant to players of
all skill levels and you on
um hello two people in the chat as well
right now and anyone watching later on
YouTube glad you are here tonight we're
talking about Intermezzo Intermezzo is a
tactic in chess
where someone plays a move and there's
kind of an expected sequence right
normally this will happen maybe there's
a trade and you expect they'll trade
back or it's just kind of a normal type
of move and then out of nowhere you play
this move that happens in between you're
doing something uh that's not expected
but actually gets you some Advantage
there's a lot of different names for
this so Intermezzo is one in between
move is another uh zosin Zug I think
it's the German for it if anyone watches
uh Gotham chess I believe he refers to
this as danger levels so there's lots of
different terms for this one idea but
I'm going to kind of illustrate what the
basic thing is and how it happens and
how to look out for in your games
so here's our first example and it's a
fairly normal one but the idea is here
in this position it's uh I believe white
to move and in the game white decided
okay I see a rook's attack The Bishop's
attacked I'm going to solve all of this
by first taking the queen
and the idea is now after black
recaptures the queen then something like
this Rook can maybe move to defend this
bishop or there's different ideas
depending on what happens if white
capture sorry if black capture is poorly
here maybe something like Knight takes
D7 maybe there are some ideas of
attacking this Pawn although still
probably not because we have an extra
Knight defending but regardless this is
White's plan is first to trade queens
and then to kind of go from there
but we have an Intermezzo in this
position and actually probably the most
common type of Intermezzo which is a
check
so in this position instead of Simply
recapturing the queen with one of our
pieces
first black plays this in between move
Knight takes F3 check attacking the king
the queen has no chance to escape from
this so you will take the Knight back
and then we recapture the queen
and the benefit here is that not only
did we trade Queens but black actually
got this extra Rook right if we look
back at this position the material is
totally even
and after Queen takes if we just take
back right away again something like
this then maybe Rook F4 and
the position is still totally equal but
because we spot the center meso we can
still get the queen but we get the Rook
first so after Knight takes we win a
full Rook you win then get the Knight
for it so it is a we are up in exchange
essentially
this is probably the most common type is
there will be some way to break a
sequence of moves through a check but
there are other ways to do it as well
for example let's take a look at our
next position here
a sort of similar idea although it's not
a check that's going to happen this time
and in this position it's white to move
and white takes a look and says okay
hold on a minute this Rook is really
beautifully attacked by my queen and
this Pawn is pinned right this Rook if
we were to take the Rook then White's
Rook would take our Queen on D7 so white
happily takes this rook and thinks not
only have I won The Rook I'm also making
an attack on this Knight and there's a
lot of threats going on in this position
but black has a very uh strong move to
respond here so if you see it at home or
if you want to type it in the comments
or whatever feel free and we're going to
be doing a lot of puzzles this evening
so anyone in the chat please uh feel
free to comment your ideas or ask
questions the move in this case is not a
check right we can maybe move the Knight
to call check or something but that's
not really what's relevant here the
problem is this pin on the queen
so the move here is actually Queen to G4
and this is not a check but it is a
forcing move because now black is
threatening to play Queen takes G2
Checkmate defended by the Knight and
there's not really a good way to stop
this probably the best move would be for
white to realize their Queen is gone and
just take the Knight and we can take
back
uh but white ended up losing uh their
Queen for a rook in a night so again not
the end of the world
um if they played a move like G3 it
would certainly be worse now it's just a
rook for a queen because this Pawn is
pinned and can't take the Knight but
either way the point stands white is
losing material because they overlooked
an Intermezzo they were expecting the
normal continuation to happen
but in this case we put a move in
between remove in this case uh the
object of the PIN and end up losing
material
so really any Intermezzo is going to
involve some kind of forcing move for
those who aren't familiar I did electron
forcing moves a while ago so I'd
recommend checking that out or finding
some other good content on it but the
idea of a forcing move is really simple
it's a move that you play that your
opponent kind of has to respond to or
they're going to be in trouble so the
most common examples are captures and
checks Checkmate threats anything like
that
and if you can see forcing moves it's
often going to help you in these type of
positions where if you follow the
expected sequence maybe your opponent is
doing fine but sometimes there's a good
chance to get an edge with an intermezzo
I want to show two different examples
from different openings of Chess and
we're going to look at both of these
from the black side the first one we're
going to look at is in the philidor
defense so that goes E4 E5 Knight to F3
and then black plays D6 to defend their
Pawn
this opening is still seen at all levels
but it's fallen out of favor at the
highest level to some extent it's a
little bit too passive right black is
blocking in this bishop but nevertheless
it's still an opening that you ought to
know it's there's nothing like forcibly
lost about this position
uh so here uh there's a few different
moves but if white responds to D4 black
has to move Bishop to G4 pinning the
Knight right D4 the idea is white would
like to open up a lot of lines put a lot
of pressure on this E5 pawn and Bishop
to G4 creates a pin
now the Knight cannot move so uh there's
only one theoretically attacker and
defender on this Pawn
however there's a bit of a trick here
after d takes E5 black has a slight
problem
because the move we would like to play
the very natural expected move is to
just recapture with our d-pawn
but there is a slight problem here if we
retake with the d-pawn it is true that
the Knight cannot take because of the
PIN
but there's actually a way around it
white can kind of play this Intermezzo
right instead of them taking they first
take the queen with check
and now notice how their Queen is no
longer on D1 it's gone which means this
Knight is not pinned and they can take
on E5 winning upon and also making a
farther threat hitting our Bishop
threatening to Fork our uh rook and pawn
there's our King and Rook now black can
defend this by just moving back but
either way white is still up a very
clean healthy Pawn on the opening and
black has lost castling rights so even
though Queens are off the board the fact
that white May one day be able to Castle
and quickly activate a rook could still
be a nice advantage
okay but not all hope is lost for our
friend here with the black pieces
because in this position
there is a way to play this move we just
have to play an Intermezzo first so
instead of recapturing the pawn right
away and allowing the queen trade and
then the Knight to take the pawn the
first thing black does here is actually
get rid of the Knight
Bishop takes F3
Queen takes F3 and then takes the pawn
back if they take with the g-pawn it
doesn't really make a difference because
either way the Knight that was here and
was threatening our E5 Pawn is no more
and so we haven't lost material now
there might still be problems with this
opening but that's beyond the scope of
this lecture the point is that using
this Intermezzo black can actually at
least maintain material quality
another opening that involves an
Intermezzo and I think the one more
famously known for it actually comes out
of the scotch game
so white plays E4 E5 Knight F3 and this
time we see Knight C6 more standard most
people are used to seeing this move
D4
which is uh the first move of the scotch
game
or the first move indicating the scotch
game I should say white immediately
fighting against E5 once again
and uh he takes D4 the main move
continuing with Knight takes D4 and we
have our still continued Scotch they
could have played something like Bishop
C4 gone into a scotch Gambit or maybe C3
and this would be more like a Goring
Gambit I believe but Knight takes D4 is
the mainline a lot of games have
happened in this position
from here one possible move is for black
to play Bishop to C5 adding some
pressure
some people might say well what if I
just take this right away and you can
but now this queen normally wouldn't
want to be out in the center in this
case it's not so big a deal because we
don't have our Knight here anymore to
provoke it so it's a little harder to
harass
so instead Bishop to C5 just adding an
extra attacker and potentially eyeing up
the F2 Square I'm just getting on a nice
diagonal here
and in this position uh one of the moves
white can play is to say okay instead of
defending this Knight maybe with
something like C3 or Bishop E3 I will
just trade it off it's not worth dealing
with so Knight takes on C6 and in this
position black again has a dilemma
just like in the Philadelphia position
we would like to capture with our d-pawn
in this case it would be on C6 but we
Face a similar problem we're not
actually going to lose a pawn here but
we are going to still lose castling
rights right if we play D take C6 and
white takes Our Queen and we take back
our King will no longer be able to
Castle which is maybe a minor
disadvantage for us so we would like to
avoid this if possible on the other hand
the other way of taking right over here
B take C6 also not ideal because now
we're doubling our pawns but in a way
that's less productive e takes D6 or
sorry D takes C6 my apologies opens up a
line for this bishop to develop into the
game on this more standard diagonal
maybe it goes into the center or comes
here to be a little more aggressive and
sometimes we'll have the bishop come
this way but it's not preferred if we
can open up the center
so what can black do in this position to
get around this problem well they can
play an inner meso where we remove the
queen
by playing Queen to F6 and threaten
checkmate
in this position there's no way that
white can save this Knight there's
actually no checks no attacks nothing
you can do you can't come back and
defend this Pawn so the Knight has
nothing it can do it's going to get
taken anyway
white has to play some move to defend
this pawn something like Queen to D2 for
example and then black can take they
could take with the queen if they really
don't want to double their pawns but
probably better is to take with the pawn
and open up this diagonal for the bishop
to develop on maybe play something like
Bishop D7 and quickly Queen side Castle
or you know they have some options but
they have not been forced to trade
queens and give up castling rights and
this is still a very normal game
so these are two open examples of inner
mesos again the idea is our there's kind
of an expectation of what's going to
happen either some trade that they'll
take and will take back or just some
very normal sequence where we can defy
the expectation by finding a nice
forcing move usually a check sometimes
it'll be a capture or like a major
threat
but
um these are some opening examples that
demonstrate that
now one thing I want to show is how an
Intermezzo can go wrong and this opening
I don't really know what the opening is
I was more just trying to demonstrate
this point but I've seen this a fair
amount in beginner games something like
this so let's just say D4 Knight to F6
F3 would be an unusual move but just for
sake of argument E6 E4 B6 E5
and in this position a player with the
black pieces might play something like
uh an Intermezzo thinking okay you've
attacked by Knight but now I'm going to
attack something more important Bishop
to B4 check attacking the king and now
you don't have time to take my knight
well this is true
but it's not really helpful because the
problem is black has created a threat
that white can respond to in a way that
creates a counter threat
so white here can play the move C3 and
now black has two problems both the
Knight on F6 and the bishop on B4 are
hanging and you actually can't save both
you are going to have to pick and choose
so probably the best will be to maybe
play Bishop take C3 or do something to
try and get a little bit out of it or
maybe just Bishop back to E7 and then
take the Knight back but regardless this
is not a good spot to be in so just
because you can play on an Intermezzo
and you can delay your opponent from
doing the expected thing right in this
case they would expect black to move
this Knight somewhere
just because we can do that doesn't mean
um we should so really think about
instrumentals before you play them they
can be an extremely powerful tool but
it's not like a Panacea or anything
another example here uh sort of of
Intermezzo gone wrong but kind of just
an Intermezzo type thing on both sides
it's in this position white plays the
move D5 to attack the queen and end its
defensive this Knight trying to create
some double problems and black could
play a few different moves here and
perhaps just Queen to E8 would be the
simplest defending the Knight by x-ray
but here black try to get a little
creative and thought I'm going to play
an Intermezzo instead of the natural
move of moving my queen I'm going to
play Rook from F to E8 and the idea is
kind of interesting now if we take the
queen
then black will take our Queen
perhaps lifting up their Rook maybe
getting ready to double it and our Pawn
on C6 is going to be pretty weak and
it's stuck on a light Square we have a
dark sword bishop and it might be easy
for black to pick up so this might be a
reasonable Advantage additionally
there's really there's no trick here of
taking the Rook that would be a nice
Intermezzo because then the queen
captures and the queen has gotten out of
Harm's Way right so R if we tried this
as an Intermezzo as like a counter
threat it doesn't work because black
will respond by
getting out of the original thread
the problem for black is that they're
going to get out intermesode essentially
and there's actually a few ways to do it
so here in this position
it's white to move again anyone in the
chat is always free to comment with
suggestions but there's actually a
couple options here
this is not a good move again as a
reminder Queen takes E8 because this
queen will take back if the Rook takes
back that would be great we'll take the
queen and win a rook but black should
take back with the queen
so instead the two moves that are much
better so uh bophatic in the chat with
Queen takes G7 this is the second best
move this is a really nice suggestion
Queen takes G7 with the idea that
um okay
well you tried to enter resume but now
I'm still going to get your queen at the
end of this so if I take a piece or a
pawn in this case
then I'm going to take something with me
this is kind of like the if I'm going
down you're going down with me principle
after something like King takes then
Pawn takes on C6 and now we've at least
picked up this Pawn so that's a little
better
um someone suggesting King H1 not not
quite sure I'd agree in this position I
mean it's still kind of weird because
there's both Queens hanging but there is
a lot better and dark tiger 3 has found
the other move and this is actually a
lot better because not only can we win a
pawn we can actually win a knight
Queen takes E4 and the problem here uh
is now if Rook takes then we'll still
take the queen and the Queens will be
traded but white just won a night for
nothing right we'll have this extra
Bishop sitting here and if you save your
queen then we can save ours so either
way you just lost material
so again something to be careful of
Black tried to get an inner meso here
with Rook to F to E8 which is a nice
looking idea but unfortunately it fails
because white can choose sense the
threats right we're threatening a queen
they're threatening Our Queen since
these threats are of equal value then we
don't actually mind
which one happens first if we can get
something out of it ourselves
okay now let's run through a few
different
um practice problems now that we have an
understanding of what an inner meso is
and how to look out for it again the
critical idea is you want to look for
forcing moves in situations where
normally your thought pattern might just
be oh I'm just going to recapture this
piece or I'm just going to move out of
danger whatever the normal expected
behavior is we're going to look for
something a little different
and one of the reasons that intermezzos
are actually I think a little harder to
practice and prepare for
um oh one quick comment about this
previous position was if the F1 Rook was
on C1 this wouldn't work
um so let's say Rook f58 if this work
was over here we can imagine
um
yeah I think the idea you're getting at
is because black would have tricks of
taking our Rook with check
um yeah that's a relevant feature that
could come up sometimes like they could
take a rook with check and then take the
queen so they would be winning a rook
that would be the same idea so good good
comment there
but one of the problems with I think
practically studying intermezos is
they're very contextual because like any
puzzle that we come across right this is
one for an example so feel free to think
about this while I'm explaining this
idea any puzzle we look at is already
divorced from whatever chess game it's a
part of
um we just come and see a board and have
to make a decision and often we know
okay this is a critical position so I'm
going to spend some more time here
trying to figure out what the right
answer is whereas in a game it's hard to
know which positions are critical
especially if it's just like a normal
capturing exchange or you know just very
natural looking moves
so I'm going to try with some of these
examples to give a little bit of context
before the immediate move in this
position it's actually fairly
straightforward but it is
um black to move here
and the move played in this game was
Knight takes H7
and Rook takes H7 and now black to move
this one should be fairly obvious but
how should black continue
what do we think
uh yes pumpkin the cat love your name
Rip takes G8 yes this is check again the
most common way to
to show an Intermezzo most of the time
it will be checked because it's the most
forcing right it actually you have to
legally according to the rules of the
game play a move that answers it the
expectation I think from White here was
that
um simply The Rook will take the rook
and then the bishop will take back and
it's all hunky-dory but unfortunately we
can take this first actually remove the
defender of this rook and after the king
moves anywhere we can capture the second
rook and be quite satisfied
so yeah this is quite bad for white
our second example here
and in this one the move that black
plays it's kind of a complex position
lightens up some material but looks like
maybe this Castle is a bit under Fire
there may be an attack going on here the
move played in this game was Bishop to
H3
and so it is now White's turn to move
and to try and find a good way to
continue so again take a second with
this position and see what you can find
how should white continue
all right we have a full line here from
bedrush okay looking at Bishop takes F4
and dark tiger is showing a line I think
it's the same very similar Bishop takes
F4 Bishop takes F1 and then Bishop to G3
attacking the queen which means we'll
have time to take so yeah let's let's
break this down um rookie 4 is
interesting as a pin but practically
Bishop E4 uh just makes it a little
simpler first we're going to take a
knight so we're going to get a piece
Black's going to take our Bishop they're
going to get a piece back and the
expectation would be that okay normal
moves will take this piece back and then
black will take and it's just a total
even trade but because we have this
Intermezzo of Bishop to G3 attacking the
queen and defending our Bishop this
queen has to move and it doesn't matter
where let's say H3 but it doesn't matter
because this bishop is attacked a lot
and white is just going to win a piece
other things that could have happened
here right if the queen takes F4
immediately then the queen is no longer
defending this bishop so that's not
going to work either
but yeah really well spotted so again
these types of things you want to look
out for where maybe you take a piece and
then move to defend there's a and this
is actually one of those interesting
examples that isn't a check right when
the threat we're making the forcing move
is attacking the queen so it's good to
kind of expand your horizons Beyond just
a check
all right here's another example to take
a second and think out a lot of pieces
on the board a lot going on
um in this game there's a few different
moves that could be played but white
chose to play uh First bishop to E3 to
attack the queen
Queen moves to B4 and they drop the
bishop back to attack the queen again
Queen goes to A4
and here's the position I'm going to
start us with so if you have white what
moves might you consider in this
position see if you can find the best
continuation
okay a few people suggesting uh pushing
our C Pawn what's the reasoning here why
might we want to push this what's going
on
okay bad Russia is saying if Queen takes
Queen then ah yes good I Bishop takes
here with check okay does black have any
other options after C5
perhaps but
um A3 is the Instinct
um yeah A3 perhaps I guess to avoid
losing this Pawn but not exactly uh
we can make a bigger threat here and our
King always can try and escape this way
if it really needs to
um but yeah C5 is just a very nice move
because it's a triple attack we're
attacking the queen we're attacking the
Knight and we're attacking the bishop
and it's kind of it's really hard to
find a move to play here
um yeah King W1 is a very safe move but
we have a nice tactical opportunity and
yeah the problem is if you move this
Knight anywhere then the queen hangs so
you can't move the Knight
if you take the bishop then
what would we continue with if if Bishop
takes on D3
yeah that's an interesting Insight so
Knight might be trapped
um possibly
I think if Bishop takes D3 Queen takes
um let's say like Knight to D5 yeah this
is probably okay
black will probably survive this uh but
the Intermezzo idea is if they take the
queen kind of fall for a mistake
or fall for our trap we take with check
first and then uh Rook recaptures so
yeah really nice found again this is not
to say like again as we saw in this
example black actually could have
survived right Knight to D5 would have
been a better move uh or I'm sorry first
they have to take the bishop
but then Knight to D5
um would have been a better move
but they didn't see the full sequence
and we're still making a lot of threats
so yeah C5 setting a trap here for an
intermezzo
all right our next example here this one
is very very simple
um I probably should have started with
it a little bit earlier but in this
example black is kind of crushing in
terms of material but Queens are on the
board and both kings are fairly exposed
so black should win this game with their
three extra pawns but unfortunately they
made a blunder and thought okay you're
attacking my queen with your knight
I will attack your queen with my knight
for some exchanges and then just promote
and win what is the problem with this
move the obvious problem
because if we play into their
expectations of just takes takes
then obviously black is very happy to be
up that material
um
but yes Queen to C2 is the problem check
and if Knight drops back to C5 then our
Queen is not attacked anymore their
Queen still is
and there's really nothing else you can
do you can block with the queen but
every Square you could block with is
undefended so really there's no way to
save the queen for black in this case
probably the best is actually just to
leave it here so that you can at least
get this Knight for it
um but this type of end game
might take a little bit of finessing but
white should not be in too much trouble
here
all right our next example actually
features a really common pattern and I
want to see what people can find so in
this position it's black to move and
sort of unclear exactly what opening
this was there's probably a few things
that could have started as maybe it was
a king's Indian maybe it was like a
Queen's Gambit declined but regardless
this is the position we find ourselves
in and it is black to move and find a
nice idea and I'm also going to show you
an idea that looks nice but does not
work which is what was played in the
game that I uh stole this from
yeah could have been a French as well we
still have this bishop back here that's
also possible
all right few people in the chat uh Zeus
does Feld 65 and debauchery Das both of
you have the right idea with Knight
takes E5
um this is a very common pattern this is
not exactly the intermezza but we will
get there Knight takes E5 a very nice
move and white here has a problem where
there is a discovered attack on this
bishop
but they can't take the bishop back
right if they take then the Knight takes
I mean they can they probably should but
they've lost this Pawn for no reason
because we just traded Bishops and then
I jumped in here if you take the Knight
then I take the bishop and black is
Happy why did I classify this as an
inner meso it's because uh black saw
this idea but found the wrong way to do
it they played Knight takes D4
thinking oh I have this attack on the
bishop and you can't do anything about
it right because if you take my knight I
take your Bishop the problem here is
again Intermezzo with Knight takes C5
there is none because if the bishop
takes with check the Knight recaptures
but after taking on D4 you have this
Intermezzo of Bishop takes D7
now this is check and after black
recaptures the night will be lost for a
pawn
um black can probably try and get this
Pawn back but either way the Knight is
lost for a pawn or two not a great
Exchange
um yeah so that's that's the actual
Intermezzo what actually happened in
this game was Knight C takes D4 this is
more what black should have played but I
think it's still useful to see this kind
of common pattern of knowing that these
pawns are weak because the Knight can
jump and defend and there's this
discovered attack so a little bit of
extra credit for this one
all right another uh puzzle here
so in this position it's white to move
and white played I believe
yeah knight from C takes E5 trying to
kind of hold everything together these
Knights are defending each other uh very
nicely maybe trying to set up some
threats against the black king
disconnecting white or sorry
disconnecting black from uh this Knight
so a few different ideas here but now it
is black to move and gain a really nice
advantage
foreign
so anyone have any ideas how black
should continue
okay a few different suggestions I have
Knight D takes F3 uh Knight E2 check
Queen takes
five I think I saw
a lot of different ideas here
so take some time and really think about
this puzzle and what our goals are
what's going on
yeah I think bedrush has the best idea
dark tiger I see I think said a similar
thing the trick here is Knight to E2
check and the problem for white is we
have this sequence
after Knight to E2 track white will be
forced into playing one of two moves
they can either play King 2 H2 or sorry
one of three moves King to H1 or H2 or
King to F2 and the best is probably King
to F2 and this is actually why it's an
inner meso after Knight to E2 King to F2
then Queen takes C5 because we have
opened up this pin on the Knight
really really beautiful we're also
defending our own and maybe making some
threats of discovered checks against
this queen but either way we have won a
knight so this is really nice and
there's no way for the king to avoid
this uh if you go over here it gets
worse right something like King H2 I
forget who in the chat said F4 yeah bed
Rush Queen F4 is just crushing because
you either step back
and we transpose into if you've gone to
H1 originally or you play G3 and then I
can take with the queen I can take with
the Knight and fork
whatever I want this is going to be very
very good and in either case if you had
gone back to H1 instead then there is
this really nasty triple Fork
so black is quite happy regardless
all right a couple more to practice with
in this position it's white to move and
it you can actually just try and figure
it out from here there's some really
nice ideas at Play
but again keeping Intermezzo in mind is
the way that we'll be able to solve this
puzzle so
see what you can come up with
so Knight to D5 does look like a fork
but there's got to be a little more to
it than that
what's the what's the trick here after
Knight to D5 well it seems like there's
a problem for black because uh this
queen and Bishop are hit and you need to
do something to well there's no way
actually to move the queen right if we
play this move the queen can't move and
defend this bishop anywhere because if
it goes back here then it's not defended
if it goes here then the knight's
attacking that square so the only move
to try is to play Queen takes B3
but then we have our Intermezzo right if
we just take back this queen then the
bishop escapes so we take the bishop
with check knowing we will get the queen
in a moment the king moves somewhere
let's say H7 and we take the queen and
we won this bishop so again really nice
idea and it's not as simple as the fork
because you also then have to calculate
okay what if they take my queen
well the truth is it's okay because we
don't have to take back right away we
actually get this really nice intermezzo
all right next example here
and this one is black to move
and it's a really interesting struggle
white is up a pawn and really it seems
like the central battle is about pushing
this Pawn white has managed to
infiltrate on the seventh
um
so there's a lot of kind of features
going on here but black has a way to
gain a nice uh advantage in this
position
and there are a lot of different ways to
exchange so it's okay if it takes you a
minute for this one something that comes
up in intermezzos a lot is this idea of
the order of operations right so which
pieces do we take first if a lot of
pieces are attacking the same square
then how do I know which one to take
first and you have to calculate it out
because it can really change things
um okay A lot of people are suggesting
Rook to D5 and the problem is white has
a lot of options so let's say after work
to D5 certainly you have to do something
because your queen is attacked
Rook 85 is a good start
um but let's say yeah Queen takes B5 I
think is a natural looking move the
problem is after the queen trade we are
still going to do what we did last time
we're going to delay taking back the
queen because we have a check on D1
that's kind of the classic Intermezzo
there
um but let's say if they do something
else so after Rook takes D5 is there
anything else that can be played
well not really because we have doubled
Rooks on the D file and just moving the
queen to defend the Rook is not quite
enough there's no Intermezzo checks that
white can dry it's just not quite enough
but it's really important to find that
move the fact that it's okay if black
loses their Queen to this trade because
we have this with check and we'll
recapture and none of the other moves
actually get us there right so if we
play Queen takes D5 this doesn't work
because now Queen takes Rook takes Rook
takes Rook takes and we didn't actually
win anything actually white is the one
who's winning material they're going to
eat up these pawns and kind of keep our
King locked away so it's actually white
with the advantage here
and similarly if we instead start by
taking this queen it also doesn't get
anything because after Rook takes it's
this same story so you have to be very
very careful when you're in these end
games and you think about okay do I want
to trade do I want to take do I want to
take uh thinking about what you take
with first is actually kind of amazing
right taking with the queen here or here
is
white at a slight Advantage but taking
here is black and a massive Advantage so
yeah really take some time with your
exchanges
um with no work on d8 white could return
with King C2
I'm not sure if I fully see what you're
talking about dark tiger
um
White's work on D1 is skewered
ah yes yes yeah you were kind of just
explaining that idea and there's no King
C2
um okay
next example here
and this one is uh
eaf for sure dark tiger this one is
black to move
and also a little bit tough so see what
you can figure out here I'll just let
you all take a look at this position
obviously if you're watching on YouTube
or something later feel free to pause
and take plenty of time to think about
this we're going to be going a little
faster
um on Twitch but yeah see if anyone can
have an idea this one is a little
trickier to figure out
and there's actually only one way to get
an advantage here white is up two pawns
and so if we don't do something quite
drastic as black and find precisely how
to continue we're going to be down at
least two points
but yeah the other tricky thing is to
notice there's a lot of potential for
exchange anytime you see a lot of
potential for exchange you really want
to stop and think right there's the
chance of this night taking this bishop
Our Queen taking here the Rooks can be
exchanged
um maybe there's sacrificial ideas on
each on H3 this Bishop's attacking our
Rook like there's just a lot to consider
okay uh zostas Zeus I don't know how to
say your name I'm going to call you
Azusa
um unless you give me something better
to pronounce it Azusa is suggesting uh
Rook takes E1 first and then Queen takes
D6
okay
um
debauchery Das is suggesting Queen takes
the I'm guessing D3 is what you mean
Knight F5 Queen 2 C5
and then taking here okay so we have a
few different ideas going on
uh twm take Bishop
and then Knight takes bishop and then
check so you're looking at the same idea
as well
yeah so okay so we have a conflict now
we have some people who want to take the
rook and some people want to take the
bishop only one of these is going to
work so see if you can figure out why
one of them works and the other one
doesn't
uh let's see
later five
yeah dark tiger I think you are starting
to see the right idea the problem with
taking the bishop is if we play Queen
takes D6
then this check actually isn't any good
clean to C5 or even Queen to B6 doesn't
really matter because Knight to E3 uh is
defended white is actually doing quite
well here so you have to start by taking
the Rook but why is this such a problem
for whites well the issue
is now when white has a few different
moves you could try if you play
just something like Queen takes C1 or
Rook takes C1 the problem here
is that we take on D6
and if they play Knight takes F5 our
Rook is defending and we just pick up a
piece
it's kind of like magic how did that
happen wait so we trade Rooks okay and
then we take the Bishops but why can't
we do that before well the reason this
doesn't work before in the other
variations if we don't trade the Rooks
then white is going to trade right we
can't play this move because white is
going to take our Rook it's not defended
something like this
um
then yeah Knight takes F5 if even if we
don't I guess we have to play the check
here but we also just can't pick up this
Knight
um
because we also have to be worried about
these check ideas of losing our Rook
so yeah you start with Rook take C1
and then
probably the best here is actually for
them to take on f8 but we also again
have this Intermezzo here of Rook takes
F1 check and then whatever takes back we
can
take this bishop or save ours or
whatever we want to do but we're still
going to be
doing okay something like Knight takes
f8 and yeah we're fine we're defended
so again a little more complicated but
always really important to think about
all the levels of you know what can be
exchanged and really take some time to
evaluate that
all right one more example here and then
I'm going to show you two examples that
are a little more advanced applications
of this technique
and then a few final comments and a game
or two to look at so in this position it
is white to move and the expected moves
are what right white would love to take
this Knight it's hanging
but problem is this is pinned so how can
we resolve this problem
dark tiger sorry to disappoint we
actually have a grand master coming to
do a lecture right after I finish up
around 7 30. so please do stick around
at that time it should be really fun
okay yeah so a few people's finding the
right idea in the chat here so we can't
take the night because of the pin so
what do we do similar to that
Philadelphia uh example first thing we
or the scotch Gambit we move the piece
out of the way Queen to F1 check and now
we're just going to take the Knight
that's not really anything you can do
um one slight complication is what if uh
Queen to F1 and black plays Queen to F7
now what do we do
because there are some sneaky little
things happening in this position you
have to be a little careful of
yeah but after taking pumpkin the cat
both got it right uh we just take the
queen first we'll take the queen and
then and then we'll be able to take the
Knight afterwards it's important not to
take the Knight right away
because if we do that
um then what can black do to cause us
some problems
right taking the queen is the simpler
way to see it but actually this just
flat out does not work
how can black get us in a lot of trouble
here
uh
okay Bishop H2 I actually did not see
um Bishop H2 is a good move yeah there's
no idea it's not Knight takes uh D5
because the queen is pinned but Bishop
to H2 is yeah a really nice move you can
even do better
um the idea here is we want to deflect
the king away from the queen
so you can also just play Bishop to D4
as as you suggest said Bishop to D4 will
also work this is a little better
because you're not having to sack the
bishop but either way the king is forced
to move away and we're just losing our
Queen so this is an uh oh again really
want to think about your move orders and
making sure it's okay again this is this
is actually again black getting an
Intermezzo if we're not careful right if
we just do the expected move then black
causes us a lot of problems by not just
trading Queens
all right so a few more advanced
applications
uh this position
is a little more complicated and the
reason Intermezzo is so tricky is
because when you as you've seen in some
of these examples but as it gets higher
and higher level
um is you have to start combining
tactics combinations is uh something
incredibly important in chess and when
we're looking at combining tactics like
the Intermezzo it can be with really
anything at all because it's just about
defying expectations so whether you're
finding pins that are involved or a back
rank Checkmate or a fork or whatever it
is all of these things can be brought
together into an intermezzo so see what
you make of this position with white to
move
what can we do again some complications
here our Queen is attacked
um
that's really the major thing to
initially worry about but otherwise see
what you can find how might white do
okay pumpkin the cat says Bishop takes
B4 as an idea yeah okay it is an idea
let's think about it Bishop takes D4
what happens okay so obvious let's start
with what if they just take our Queen
yeah it's okay if we don't know if it
works let's but let's kind of explore it
a little bit so if they take our Queen
after Bishop takes B4
well I think the kind of obvious problem
is or for um for black the problem is
okay well we'll take their Queen right
this bishop was there's a discovery
right yeah exactly so takes or sorry
takes takes takes
um and now black actually has to be
still careful right because our Bishop
is hanging and we could say okay wait a
minute what if they just take back with
the pawn of the Knight
okay what's the problem then
okay a pumpkin cat saying yes then
Knight takes before so no good but hey
you found it the back rank right so you
can play Bishop takes D4 and if Rook
takes takes you can't take the bishop
back because we have a back rank threat
this is where the combinations all come
together right so always be keeping an
eye out don't just discount a move
because you're like oh I don't know if
it works I'm not saying you did that in
the chat but
um it's always good to see things
through okay but there is more going on
so Bishop takes B4 okay so what if black
instead of um taking our Queen what
happens if they just take the Rook
this is I think a little simpler why
can't they just take the Rook actually
uh yeah so the nice thing here is our
Queen is defending right so we can pull
our Queen out of the way and then there
is no idea of Rook takes E4 our Queen's
not there anymore okay so we can
discount both of these moves they're not
going to work
um what if black just Retreats what if
they play like Queen to D7 here
now what do we do because they're still
attacking both our Queen and our Bishop
right
what would we do there if Bishop takes
and then just the queen goes to D7
now what do we do
because black is not forced to take
either The Rook or the queen
do we have an answer are we going to
have to move our Queen and then uh lose
the bishop we're not dark tiger 3 found
it again Queen takes D5 in that line
really really nice after the queen drops
back Queen takes D5 because we still
have this back rank threat the queen now
is overburdened by defending the Knight
and the back rank Square you can't take
here and so we're winning a piece and
you also can't take the bishop back at
any point because the queen is hanging
so this is a big problem
um It's actually kind of hard to stop
the back rank here and save your queen
probably have to play something like
Queen E8 so yeah that doesn't work okay
final example
Bishop takes B4 uh what if just Knight
takes they just take back immediately
I think this is probably the computer's
preferred move
uh oh question about Queen takes E6
Queen takes E6
no pontics yeah you you already spotted
that
um Queen hangs but Queen is defended by
The Rook
so if Bishop takes Knight takes then the
queen is defended
oh you're talking about The Rook takes
I'm sorry yeah Rook takes but then they
still can't take what The Rook here
because the back rank so again it gets a
little complicated Bishop takes if
Knight takes B4 then we don't take with
the queen we take with the rook and
again Black Faces this back rank issue
you can't take our Queen because of this
um so probably you have to take back
like this and
it's imbalanced you still have some
stuff to fight with but we have this
clean
it's very very good
um so this is where something like an
Intermezzo gets really fun and
interesting is where we're looking at
all of these tactics together we're
looking at this discovery we're looking
at potential pins we're looking at back
rank threats and this is where you can
see how even players at a high level can
miss these things
let me show one more
kind of advanced tactic this is a really
pretty one
in this position it is white to move and
find just a really beautiful move and
it's hard because this is very
complicated there's a lot of pieces
attacking right this bishop is attacking
this Rook but it's pinned uh to the
queen this Knight is attacking this Rook
but it's pinned to the queen there's a
lot of pieces hitting this bishop
there's a king side attack potentially
going on this is kind of a crazy absurd
position
but there's some really really
interesting ideas here so see what you
can find with white to move yeah I know
it's a lot I know it's a lot but I think
it shows some really interesting ideas
okay zusa you suggest Bishop E3 you're
gonna have to elaborate
uh Theodore heart Bishop B through I'm
guessing that was a mistype on E because
the bishop can't go to B3 maybe B2 is
what you're saying Bishop takes on The
Rook could be so these are two
suggestions possibly so far
yeah dark tiger now maybe I think you're
starting to see it so Bishop E3 is
actually the move this is kind of crazy
because we're opening up this attack on
our Queen
but it's an Intermezzo because we'll
take their Queen with check and then
still pick up the Rook now it gets more
complicated right this is probably more
complicated than is fair for a beginner
breakdown
um but the basic idea is yeah Bishop E3
and there's a few things going on is one
we're threatening this check two we're
threatening d8 and there's not a good
way to stop both right if you just move
the queen out of the way this is
actually just checkmates we're fully
cutting off the king
so you can't do that
and if you do something like you know
move the king out of the way then we'll
take the queen you can take and take and
even here you can't try and make it kind
of complicated by taking a knight or
something because we have this the Opera
mate
that's not good for black so here
probably the best would be Rook takes D3
we'll take the queen with check and then
there's this F6 idea which can kind of
complicate it a little bit but we can
just take and let's say they take
we just trade a bunch here on F6
and now we can take one of these Rooks
um probably better to take this one
and get our Knight out of Harm's Way of
the bishop
and something like this white is up a
little bit black has somehow survived
this absurd position but the important
thing is yeah again recognizing how
complex all of this can be how many
things you want to look out for and how
intermissive can play a kind of critical
role in undermining some of these
positions
a few final comments here so first as
we've already talked about the move
order that we use can be very important
right if you take the wrong thing first
it can go from winning to losing to draw
to you know everything in between
so in this position there's another
really kind of hard to find intermezzo
if you want to take just a minute I
don't want to spend too much time
because it's still a little more
advanced but see if you can find the
nice Intermezzo in this position and I'm
guessing you a lot of you will probably
find it but you might find it for the
wrong reason
it's white to move by the way if I did
not clarify that I apologize
so white to move
totally even materially some interesting
positional features here but there's a
really nice kind of Intermezzo idea to
gain an advantage
and again this is a little more advanced
than I would normally do on a beginner
breakdown but I like to show how you can
apply this at a higher level
all right so if it is uh if you're on
YouTube always feel free to pause but in
this position the move is actually
okay so Rook to G4
suggested Rook text Bishop suggested a
few things suggested actually the move
here it's kind of crazy uh okay Bishop
takes F5 yeah a lot of things uh going
on here
actually the best move there's a few
moves you can play and be okay
um but Rook to E1
with this really neat idea where we're
kind of stopping Black in their tracks
um if you play like Bishop takes D3 then
I'm going to take this rook and my king
is defending here so at least I'm
winning an exchange so that's not going
to work if you drop the Rook back
then now you've undermined this bishop
and I can take it with check so the most
common move is like okay well wait a
minute I'll just take the Rook on E1
this is where it gets really hard it's
not even that a lot of people not a lot
but some people can find Rook to E1
harder I think is to then find what do I
take this with it's not the bishop
because if I take with the bishop
then
Rook takes Rook takes and this Rook gets
away and it's about even
but here I take with the Rook
Rook takes F5 and this is basically over
because I'm hitting both Rooks and if
you take one of them I take or sorry if
you take this Rook then I take back with
check
and I'm picking up this rook and
actually you don't even get the bishop
because you can't approach it
um yeah pretty pretty brutal
um so that's a fun one
in the last four minutes I want to show
you two uh kind of positions from two
highest level games this first one is
from nimsovich uh versus capablanca
nimsovich have the white pieces and
notice that black has some material but
white is really launching this Pawn
storm
uh what happens here is white plays B5
trying to force the pawn through with
something like C6
Rook to F6 and then nimsovich just
begins an exchange you know trying to
remove some Defenders make it a little
uh easier to calculate Bishop takes E4
and instead of playing the normal move
the expected move of just recapturing
this bishop
capoba Blanca brings the house down with
a really beautiful move
very elegant
so see if you can find four black how
can we punish this capture yeah not
capturing back Zeus has got it this one
again Bishop to F2 cutting off the
king's escape and Rook to H6 is
Unstoppable
it's Force mate and there's nothing you
can do to stop it
um the absolute best you can do is to
try and delay
but
there's just nothing
so that's a really pretty one
um again a nice Intermezzo looking at
the object of it's not even a check
right this one is not a check it's just
cutting off the escape and it's a mate
and here's another one one of the most
famous intermezzos I would argue
probably ever
um this happened between uh Magnus
Carlson and viswanathan Anand in the
2014 World Championship this was from
round six and the game uh it's it's a
fun game to look at we don't have quite
the time to analyze it in depth but I'm
going to skip to the relevant position
so we get something like this
where Carlson has white and is kind of
it's a materially equal
um Carlson is kind of pushing here on
the white side the bishop pair over the
knights is a slight Advantage but Anand
is kind of holding
95 Bishop to D1 Rook to d8 Bishop back
there's kind of a repetition
and white plays uh this move again it's
a slight Edge but complicated position
and Carlson plays King to D2 and in this
position
Anand actually had a chance to gain a
serious advantage and probably going to
win this game uh Carlson is the one who
actually ends up winning but Anon didn't
see it right neither player at the this
is the highest level it's the world
championship neither player saw this
relatively easy to spot Intermezzo in
the game Anand played A4
and the game continued Carlson went on
to win by just kind of breaking through
on the uh if he King side and just
eating too many pawns and in this
position there was a resignation by
Anand
but back in a relevant position if he
looked a little closer
then there's this really really
beautiful move instead of just kind of
playing A4 and continuing Knight takes
E5
Intermezzo is the the idea here is okay
we have a discovered attack
but if you take
then it's check winning the pawn
um
if the king approaches then there's
still another check and the Knight is
just safe
we can now recapture
and black is up two pawns it's gonna
stay that way because if you take this
one I'm getting this one
it's yeah this is two pawns is more than
enough for a player at this level to win
um and there's really nothing else that
could have been done uh it's I don't
want to you know two in-depth analyze
this it's really interesting but just a
few other options if instead of taking
here obviously you cannot take the
Knight because this Rook is hanging from
the Discover attack so Rook takes E5 is
out
um
if you play something like this Rook
over here to
this file to put more pressure on this
Pawn
but maintain a defense of C4 then after
just like something like F5 white is
kind of falling apart because this Rook
is almost trapped Bishop to E8 threatens
to trap The Rook
um but there's also threats on G2 and
there's still this persistent threat
over here so there's just too many
threats
um one sample line could be something
like Rook takes H6 Rook takes Rook takes
check and yeah this is already bad
um and then yeah there's really nothing
else if just like Rook drops back to G3
then I'm not defending this Pawn anymore
so this would have been a great find for
Anand unfortunately he didn't but as
zeusa just said it's very difficult to
see these puzzles in the middle of a
game that's why I encourage you to
always be thinking about not just what
is the normal type of move a natural
type of move
um but thinking okay do I have any
opportunities to defy expectations play
something that catches my opponent off
guard with a nice in between move a
forcing check or capture or mate threat
can be a really nice way to secure an
edge in a game
that is all the time that I have with
you tonight but thank you so much for
joining I look forward to seeing you
again for another beginner breakdown but
please do stick around the stream will
continue with Grandmaster uniski quesada
Perez so my name has been Alex and it's
been a pleasure to have you and begin a
breakdown take care
[Music]
thank you